do you get a lot of down time yes yes
yes because
now like i said um uh so the few years
hard but uh you after you can manage uh
with the statue to have a kosoku
and kosoku it's been a fixed contract
you can say
and you can get paid per month okay
all right but this is salary you have to
you can negotiate together okay
so better you you have to prove yourself
okay yeah i
so you at first you have to prove
yourself yeah
yeah this is so bizarre because yeah
because like i said here you
all those uh salary of all those money
is by
yeah you don't sign contracts oh really
yes or you
get paid this amount but you say nothing
is just by
speaking so it's all verbal yes or by
mail do you get it do you get it like in
cash or like what like you said
uh bank oh my god
believes you yeah trust me we had a deal
it's freelance in japan
but that kind of goes completely against
what we talked about with like twitter
artists right
yeah like you have to like sign a
contract and like get an nda
and all that [ __ ] just to like protect
your identity where in japan it's just
like
yeah we promise we'll give you this i
have more security buying something off
ebay yes
jesus christ and you don't sign nga in
japan
yeah you you can come here and talk
about the things that you know
technically yeah i mean you were telling
it's all based on the trust system
is this true even for when they like
contact a random twitter
animator and what and ask them to work
on a new project they it's not not under
nda or anything like that
they trust you so so the animator who
could say no and be like
guys i know the next movie that's coming
out yeah
how is that like a leak every week
because
it's the trust of uh um animate
the trust of the the studio on the
animators
and if you have some links but you get
just blacklisted
yeah sure and if you get basic by you'd
find no more works yeah yeah so yeah
it's you
that's crazy it's up to you
don't [ __ ] it up i'm surprised there
hasn't been like just one person one
one rogue animator hasn't popped up in
the entire history of anime yeah that's
that's impressive
well if you mess up you send um big
names so
oh what did you done yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
jesus scary because i i guess it would
make sense because a lot of people
look up to the directors right and the
people in charge so i doubt they would
try and i guess it'd be like
backstabbing your idol
yeah right the thing that you the thing
you love right now i guess that makes
sense